welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel and this is the news
so this week we've seen that the scholar
johansson lawsuit with disney has come
to an end and it was very friendly end
to the lawsuit by all accounts
now
the details have not been released but i
think we can fairly say that it's going
to involve a lot of cha-ching
and um
i think
scarlett johansson's statement in
particular where she talks about how
she's looking forward to future projects
and this might not be a massive
financial settlement but more of a
disney kind of saying look we're sorry
this was the contract this was the
reality but how about we come away from
this friendly and um you sign this very
lucrative contract for a couple more
movies thank you very much i think we're
going to be seeing scarlett johansson in
future disney related properties
also vin diesel has teased that
the riddick series is going to be coming
back and maybe sooner than we think
the fury movie has been in development
for about four or five years now and
going back to 2019 vin diesel said that
they had a script
and i'm really excited about this
project because the chronicles of ridic
is one of my favorite classic sci-fi
movies and the last riddick movie really
was it kind of felt like a almost like a
reboot or a remake of pitch black
again a great movie and the movie from
2000 that really
um pushed um vin diesel into this
starlight and made him a proper
hollywood's hero a proper hollywood
movie star um chronicles riddick was
very popular back in 2004 and
like i said it's just a beautifully made
movie throughout and i'd really love to
see you return to that style film and be
being called furious tends to suggest
that maybe we're going to see something
more along the lines of chronicles of
riddick rather than the last rick movie
the monsters movie is in full swing and
the set is pretty much complete and
filming is about to start millie bobby
brown is going to be returning as an ola
holmes
uh the sequel is going to be filming
very shortly and obviously we're going
straight to netflix henry cavill will be
returning um as well with helena bonham
carter now this is a film that i enjoyed
the first and all holmes it was a you
know a cheeky little movie
but i always questioned henry cavill as
holmes
if you could think of an actor
least likely to play sherlock holmes i
mean you could say like dave batista or
arnold schwarzenegger or something like
that but quite high open the list for me
would be henry cavill um
he's returning i think he got this part
mainly because of a netflix contract
rather than actually being right for the
role but hey it was a fun movie and
let's see what the sequel brings
and finally todd mcfarlane comic book
writer and occasional movie maker has
been talking about the spawn reboot he's
been saying that if the film gets made
and it's a big if at the moment because
it's been a long time coming it will not
be a retelling of the original movie it
will not be a
origin story again it is going to be
looking at the later comics now back in
the day the spawn series was one of the
most popular comic books
that you could buy
this is a series in a
story that's been gagging to be told and
now with special effects the way they
are and with the popularity of r-rated
movies um in the superhero genre
maybe this time is set for a spawn
reboot so yeah this this is a film i
could see coming back quite soon and
having a really big splash and if they
had a bit of humor
they go a bit of dark humor
they have violence make it rated don't
try to make it a 12a or 15 and they
really go proper balls out
this could be a very successful very
interesting reboot so let's see what
happens
so if you're wondering why i'm doing
this in the car it's not normal but
unfortunately the um
joys of being an amateur little youtuber
here means that i sometimes have to
record where and wherever i am and i'm
waiting around for the wife so i thought
i'd get it done and get it edited while
i've got nothing better to do and if you
are new to the channel you can expect
more great content like this
and please like subscribe hit that bell
notification share the video where you
can and come and join us on facebook
it's the psytrek channel and you can
search for sidetrack or there's a link
in the description thanks very much guys
and uh car going by
we'll see you soon
[Music]